hey there well first of all I'm very
disappointed that Drake did not perform
he came on stage to talk about the new
Apple music service but unfortunately no
performance from Drake we did get a
pretty good performance up front from
Jimmy Iovine the co-founder of Beats
came on stage and he had perhaps the
most magical presence of everyone at the
keynote today
Tim Cook as he introduced Jimmy Iovine
said one more thing and the Jimmy Iovine
came on and said three more things
invoking some of job's famous words and
Apple music it's interesting it seems
like Apple is trying to be a lot in one
you can buy you can stream it's a radio
service and they're also trying to be a
social network there may be a few
services out there that do this already
but again Apple isn't isn't always first
and certainly not last but Apple
certainly trying to revolutionize how we
listen to music this global beats 1
radio service will be on all the time
curated by human beings in fact one
thing that they did say on stage is that
internet radio isn't really radio it's
just lists of songs this Apple radio
service is going to be curated by real
human DJ's $9.99 a month $14.99 for a
family plan first three months are free
okay let's talk about that pricing I was
a emailing with John Butler of Bloomberg
intelligence and he said look is $10 a
month enough to compete with Spotify
that is free is it enough to distinguish
Apple music from a meat to product that
it could also be you know we don't know
I mean as you said earlier 30 million
songs that certainly sounds like a lot
of songs it's not top tier artists
they're really reaching out across the
music community but there are other
options out there I mean you can listen
to Pandora for free why would I want to
listen to a global radio service that
isn't exactly music of my choosing
Pandora lets me choose and curate my own
radio station so there certainly are a
lot of questions around this service but
it's definitely Apple taking a huge leap
in terms of you know this is the
business that they revolutionize in the
beginning but iTunes has become you know
a laggard in this business and Apple is
trying to now get out front of the
business that it started one of the
other interesting things that we had
here today not just what the news what
news was presented but who was
presenting that news we saw the first
two women presenters on stage two Apple
executives Susan Prescott introducing
Apple's new news application and
Jennifer Bailey introducing new features
for Apple pay so certainly that is a
sign of Tim Cook this is a guy who cares
a lot about diversity a lot about social
progress putting women on stage and I
think that was another thing that got a
lot of applause here at the keynote
today yes I love that if you had to pick
one thing that sort of had or maybe a
lackluster response Emily what was it
there there are a few lackluster
responses throughout the show I mean we
saw a lot of refinements updates to iOS
you know we saw them unveil iOS 9 the
new OS 10 operating system software El
Capitan multitasking on the iPad a lot
of these little things that Apple is
attempting to sort of refine the
experience and loop all of the things
that we do with our Apple products
together the watch was definitely a lot
of interesting stuff coming out with
regard to the watch and watch kid it
just goes to show just how fast things
can develop and move when it comes to
software developers can now natively
natively produce apps on the watch which
means it doesn't have to rely on your
phone so the experience is much more
efficient much more quick there's a lot
of futuristic stuff out there one day my
watch may be able to come to control all
of the appliances in my house not quite
there yet but that's certainly the
future that they are hoping to move us
toward